hi thanks to the organizers for having
me
so this is supposed to be very nervous
talk and the point of you going to take
is more almost like an evangelical point
of view so I'm not going to go to huge
step into the whole random forest
algorithm or so but it's more I'm going
to use it as a case study as to why now
starting on data analysis is so cool
and empowering and how in the whole
language wars there's really not really
a point for language Wars or more about
okay there's so many different tools
let's just make our own bag of tools
bigger so I title random forest our vs.
Python but should be more like our in
Python so here's a big disclaimer I'm
not a Python ista actually I'm very new
to Python I'm a very very much in our
user so this was more an exercise on how
to have fun when starting on a date
analysis so that is my surname and
that's why Ian was having trouble
pronouncing it because it has so many
use so um I know but okay uh so my name
is Linda Richard - you can find me on
Twitter that's my favorite social
network my friends make jokes that I
tend to be faster answering via Twitter
than any other way including phone and I
currently work as a consultant at DVI
which is a web analytics and data
consultancy and I'm a physicist by
training I'm a reformed string theorist
so yeah so this is the outline of this
talk first I'm going to give you a
motivation as to why I'm going to be
talking about random forests and in
particular when it concerns to are in
Python then I'm going to go and discuss
random forests and their implementations
in our in Python and I'm going to focus
in a very specific example namely the MU
music set and I'm going to tell you a
story as to why this is an interesting
example and
then I'll give you some concluding
remarks so motivation so when you're
standing on in data analysis there can
be too many resources you go online you
go on Twitter maybe follow people that
do data and just go like oh this guy
says Python is the best thing or R is
the best thing or like what the hell is
the best thing so it can be quite
crowded over there
you're the kid hub there's so many
different things you then go and take
maybe a bunch of MOOCs so you go to
Crewe Sara you maybe I've done several
casseras each of them might have your
favorite language this case they can
have Python newsletters in Java they can
do are etc or MATLAB then you go to
Catalan you can if you are into cattle
competitions you can find huge red
saying like oh I did in an hour because
this is awesome so quoting from the
previous speaker yes awesome is a word
that you find a lot online and then also
Stack Overflow favorite website for
figuring out how to do things and then
you can also go to books or maybe if you
went through the school academia work
and you happen to do some technical
degree maybe some courses they pick
Python or C or C++ or anything to teach
you how to code so that's what you know
and that's how you start doing things so
the popular question is which language
should I use so if you go on Google and
say date another's language you'll find
this art well this is the Rd top results
that I found when I did the search so I
found our and then you have huge Fred's
and then MATLAB and Julia and and of
course Python somewhere over there so
this is my own experience used you start
by what you know and you asked your
friends so I my first language
programming was in C so I was first year
you need that scared me to death
because I thought it was super
complicated and sort of put me off for a
while then I start using MATLAB and I
was like okay somehow I like this
then I spent a long time playing with
symbolic languages mathematic and maple
so and then I was like I actually like
doing this and PS I had not met the
ipython notebook and if I hadn't met the
800 notebook before it would have been
much more positive out of programming at
that stage so I don't have a web
developer background and then because I
beat maths and physics I was surrounded
by people doing stats so then you pick
the right tool for the task at hand and
that's why this is the big reveal I'm an
avid our user so for me going from
mathematic and maple jumping into our
was sort of a smooth transition and it
was much later when I found all these
threads online saying like oh this
syntax this is so horrible like why
would you do that and I'm like no it's
nice so did this leads to the whole
language Wars so there's too many
articles about Python displacing our as
a programming language for data analysis
its Python release planting our for data
work 10 reasons Python rocks for
research yay um why am vetting on Julia
and these are all legit articles you can
go and find them why Python with coffee
is better than are with ice cream
actually that's that they're well TLDR
so it can be very confusing for a newbie
so this is pretty much the gist of it
insert favorite language is better
because I say so
well okay however I think it is good to
have a general understanding of the
pluses and the minuses of the various
data analysis tools in order to pick the
right tool for job so for instance our
has everything you need for performing
statistical analysis there's pretty much
a library for everything you can think
of even several libraries for the same
thing so there it goes more into ok
which of the older libraries the
splitter the tasks that I want to
perform then our MATLAB and Python are
great for prototyping Python is a
full-featured programming language so
it's easier to incorporate Python
outcomes into a full data product for
flow so each language has its pluses on
its - s
so it's good if you know if you're a bit
of a polyglot then you can talk to
people that work in specific languages
and maybe learn one or two lessons so I
think that it's better to spend time
defining the problem and determining
what is the best way to solve it so for
that is very good to have a big bag of
tricks
so I started dabbling on Python probably
later like October last year and I was
going online and I found this very nice
website where this blog called slender
means and they has this awesome section
called bullet Python so this is someone
who is an are user and he's tasked to
teach himself Python in data analysis is
to redo well he started redoing the
machine learning for hackers all the are
code but in Python just to see you know
what I can learn from Python or maybe
there's a better way of doing things in
Python compared to how I do things in R
so I said okay I'm going to take this
approach with a small project that I did
in R and try to do it in Python and see
what lessons I can learn so for that I
used as I could learn a library which is
the library of machine learning
algorithms is open source it has an API
basically it amalgamates and connects
and every with all the other Python
libraries numpy and scipy and all all
the other things that finish with P it's
accessible has many models documentation
and examples so this is pretty much a
great great resource for someone who's
just getting to grips with it yeah so it
is pretty awesome I also use the word
awesome a lot so I guess for the great
events in life then I would use super
awesome so anyway this is my example so
let's choose a problem so it's always a
good idea to look for a data set that is
interesting to you so if you're starting
data analysis and you're really serious
about it it's probably a good idea to
pick a set that you know really inspires
you to ask questions
so once you've choose a set that is
interesting to you you formulate a
question then you formulate an
hypothesis and then you probably build a
model to answer the question and test it
or test your hypothesis so this is a
scientific method for the win people
have been doing it for a long time so
let's follow this room so choose the
data set so an interesting data set that
you can find the line is the M music 1
million interview set it's in title it
was also the subject of a hackathon a
year ago two years ago it's one of the
largest preference data sets in the
world the extract is in the encargo and
it's available as four separate data
sets in CSV so the four data sets are
our training tests a set which includes
artists information track information
user ID time and ratings so this data
set pretty much pretends basically they
just asked a bunch of people set them
down presenting them with a series of
songs and ask them to say they liked it
or not and then they also had to answer
specific questions about you know
behavioral questions the mo graphics etc
so it's quite a rich data set so for
instance at the second set that you're
presented with the words data set so you
have a set of 82 objectives so every
time a person's was sat down to listen
to a song they ask this person to use
the best words to describe the song so
say maybe they put you like latest
Rihanna head you will say that it's
upbeat so then you put like one and if
it was you know not romantic you would
see zero one depending if you thought it
was romantic or not there was also
questions about if you actually own
music of this artist or if you have
heard music of this artist and etc so
that was this is containing this data
set and finally demographic information
such as gender the age their working
status their
region this is all pretty much in the UK
also had some some specific facts about
their behavior such as how many hours
per day on average do they listen to
music if they listen to music that they
own versus music that they don't own and
they might be streaming online etc and
then they were also presented another
set of questions where they actually had
to rate themselves from a scale from 0
to 100 and and these questions had to do
with the fact of how much do you agree
or disagree with the statement so for
instance you have something a statement
such as music is important to me but not
necessarily the most important so how
much do you agree or disagree with the
statement and pick one
I like music but it does not feature
heavily in my life music is no longer as
important as it used to be so write
yourself keep some number and there you
have a lot of stuff so this is actually
a not very sophisticated visualization
of the word set so you have all the
different entries rows by user per song
this ready and then if the word each
column is if the word was used or not
and how many times so for instance you
have words such as uninspired aggressive
unattractive warring cheap relevant way
are annoying cheesy inertial outdated or
approachable etc so 82 objectives and of
course there's lots of sparseness in
this matrix and then you can also look
at the word use across artists so
there's actually some words that we're
very heavily used and and if you didn't
divide this sort of bright spots this
adjectives are used a lot with regards
to specific artists so wholesome all
legendary pioneer dark so maybe it must
be someone like I don't know Bob Dylan
or the Beatles unfortunately we're not
prone as to which artist is referred to
because it's just encoded with artist ID
but then you can speculate
and finally the users data set like the
19 music avid questions so these are the
typical statements
I enjoy actively searching for
discovered music that I have never heard
before from 0 to 100 how much do you
agree with this or not I'm not willing
to pay for music I like to be at the
cutting edge of new music I love tech
etc and finally this is a distribution
of ratings that is just an Instagram and
something that is very interesting is
that actually the the rating seems to be
very highly clustered so you know how in
arm we all know this culture about the
5-star rating thing so this makes pretty
good evidence as to why five stars
actually makes sense so this is more or
less how it looks like and so why is
this data set interested to me well I
grew up with music my dad loves music
I'm very interested about how technology
has disrupted the music industry so I
found this in Gujrat infographic online
which says how your father's favorite
music indicates what you listened to
today
this is so true so yes I guess this is
pretty much good sort of psychological
motivation but also then if you look at
the landscape how technology has
disrupted the music industry you can see
that this has happened at three levels
so you have production level now is
cheaper to produce there's lower voice
24 budding artists the distribution
Internet has made music more accessible
artists can decide where and how to sell
and finally consumption so people's
listening habits have changed due to the
internet and to the change in devices so
now my question to you is like how many
questions can you think with respect to
this data set there's many different
problems that you could think of trying
to get back up for your segments from so
let's look at specific problems so for
instance if you're an artist
it's easier to produce music but it's
harder to make yourself known or earn a
living for record companies people buy
per song it's easy for a listener to
consume without paying so the
competition field is wider and then for
the listeners are so many choices this
cover is difficult so if you had all
this information about people's music
Abbot's or listening habits how can I
make use of this information in order to
help me solve this type of problems so
questions that may arise is for instance
can you predict the rating of a song so
this might be useful for discoverability
for specific engines that might suggest
you that if you like this then you like
this so as part of collaborative
filtering problems what factors are
important to determine how much person
likes a song this might be important for
marketing departments also to know for
record and record companies to know
which which musicians they should be
considering to and presenting to people
so they buy records and they generate
more revenue or what is the minimal set
of factors that are needed to determine
how much a person likes a song like can
I reduce this hugely highly dimensional
problem to a smaller problem and then
find exactly what are the triggers
behind why person would like a song so
this is just three different questions
but with respect to the three areas that
I presented before you could come up
with many other questions that you might
want to explore so I think this is very
empowering so I present you I presented
you an interesting data effect that I
thought it was interesting
I've also explained that there's many
problems that you could try to solve and
many questions that you can give answers
to so now you can formulate the
hypothesis so that was what I call step
three so let's start with the first
attempt I'm going to pick the simplest
problem so can you predict the rating of
the song well this is pretty much a
problem for prediction so you can phrase
this problem as a regression problem you
can turn categorical variables into
marek variables consider all the
features and pick a machine learning
algorithm to do the job
so this is pretty much you know the
bare-bones back up to what you want to
do and now you have want to pick what is
the best tool to solve this problem
well if because of what I explained to
you before exploit an analysis reveal
ratings are highly clustered we can look
at different at five different scores
and formulate problem also so
classification one and we can split the
ratings up 0 to 105 intervals and each
becomes a class and we can label this so
I now explain to you we have pretty much
a regression problem or a classification
problem so now I get really to the bunch
of my talk which is random forests so
this was a sort of like long-winded way
of getting to the point that I wanted to
get thought that's pretty much how you
go about solving this type of thing so
want to run them for us well aka the
best black box method ever this is
actually quite this is a quite recent
algorithm from the 90s late 80s Early
90s and it's a highly versatile
in-sample method which conveying several
models into one so for most people
classification trees are very simple to
understand because you have a set of
rules and then you pretty much can
predict something from knowing the set
of rules so random forests reveal from
aggregating trees they can be used for
regression and classification problems
they do not over fit and can handle
large amount of features and they also
output a list of features that are
believed to be important in predicting
the variable so if you're presented with
a problem as like such as the one that I
told you before well there's many
different machine learning algorithms
you can pick you can even start from a
very simple linear regression and that's
a way of solving it and then you can
either pick other type of machine
learning algorithms to do this problem
and what happens in real life is that
people that are very comfortable with a
specific machine learning algorithm will
use that for everything so if you are
very into neural networks you'll
probably use neural network
to do everything if you are into support
vector machines you'll probably do this
ad through everything or well not
everything but let's say everything that
you can use it for and but random
forests are great they might not be
super interpretable and that's why
there's a black book net method but um
you can do you can never do worse than
the order much more fancy methods so
let's do a very small layman's intro I
pretty much stole this from Edwin to
choose a chance blog it's a post so he
explains random forest in the following
way so let's consider Jaime and Brienne
so Jamie goes and tells Brienne about
his favorite movies and then brain is
like oh cool so Jamie's like I like
Titanic and I like you know Little
Mermaid I miss a closet Disney fan and I
also like the action movies and etc etc
so then Jamie wants to see if given this
information Brienne can tell Jamie if
you will like X movie so he says well
I've told you all this stuff about
movies so now would I like X movie that
I don't know I haven't watched ah what
do you think
so then friggin stars playing the famous
game of 20 questions so you know the
game of 20 questions where 20 questions
would lead you to something that you
have to guess so in this forum brianna
is pretty much the decision tree for
Jamie's movies preferences so these 20
questions are pretty much the different
nodes of your decision tree and then at
the end given these 20 questions you
might be able to tell Jamie yes you will
like this or you'll like it like that so
now let's get a bit more sophisticated
so instead of just asking Brienne
because just just one tree so let's ask
Tywin and Cersei and Tyrion and Jaime
gives each of them a slightly different
information because to be fair if I get
very excited I may go and talk to you
and tell you oh I like Tolkien movie
you know a lot of rings gay but then if
I go to other person and I might be very
embarrassed because I don't want all my
to come out all nerdy I said yes I like
them a lot but I might not be super
excited so there's some slightly
difference on information so then the
way in which Jamie tells about his movie
preferences to Tywin might be very
different to how he goes and tells them
to Tyrion or to Cersei so going about
the same procedure they form a back
forest of Jaime's movie preferences so
each of them is a different tree and
because you have this different sort of
bootstrap it and set then you have a
back forest of Jaime's movies
preferences so now the last point is if
Jaime demands getting different
questions every time so the last step
was pretty much Brienne playing the 20
questions but he wants different
questions so if this question is the
selection of these questions is random
then at the end we now form a random
forest of Jaime's movie preferences
because they're not the same questions
so this is the idea behind random
forests so much more formally a tree of
maximal depth is grown on a bootstrap
sample of size M of the training set and
there's no pruning then if you pick
under this conditions you can then start
splitting in each node and you're going
to be sampling variables out of this
point and the blessed the best split of
these variables according to specific
criteria that you might define is used
to split the node into two sub nodes etc
etc then the final classification is
given by majority boarding of the
in-sample of trees in the forests and
there's only pretty much two free
parameters the number of trees and the
number of variables in the random subset
at each node so now how do we what are
these two criterias to pretty much split
the node um well that depends on the
implementation different versions might
have different criteria usually the the
standard one is the out-of-bag ever so
each bootstrap sample not used in the
construction of the tree becomes a test
set so you basically just pick some and
then otherwise you leave it outside and
then basically the ones that you left
outside consider your new test set so
then when you apply this model into the
test set you get some miss
classification error or MSE for
regression and you have read over all
the samples and then each point you
pretty much know where you're going
right or where you're going wrong and
then also in this process you'll get
information about variable or feature
importance because you can look at how
much prediction error how much the
prediction error increases when the
out-of-bag data for the variable is per
muted will all the others are left
unchanged so you keep changing and
changing the different features and see
how that error changes with the
permutation so then if you test a
specific variable and you get like huge
miss miss classification error then it's
like oh oh go this is not a good idea
then I just change it for other one I
see oh maybe this is a better idea so
anyway that is the idea behind random
forests and then you can move on into
different implementations in your
favorite language so in R there's very
very simplement ations in different
libraries probably the most common is
the one in the random forest library but
then there's other libraries that also
have running forest implementations
carrot party and big RF and there's
probably long much more than I don't
know anything about however we're going
to follow the kiss procedure keep it
simple and we're going to test various
values up and try in the number of trees
because those are pretty much my two
free variables so I'm going to stick in
our with the random forest package so I
use a random forest package 4.67 with
our 2.15 the faults are N equals 500
trees and entra equals P over 3 for
regression and squared P for
classification
so that's what you get out of the box
and then that I did with our and then
you can try to do the same problem in
Python so for Python I use this I could
learn two point fourteen point one
running Python version two point seven
point five and then the computer that I
use is pretty much this very old MacBook
I'm still running Snow Leopard I don't
want to grade and for the comparison I
know that this is not proper
benchmarking but then again this is more
about me or anyone else going from one
language that you're comfortable with
and trying to see if you can do the same
thing in other language so I use a
training time look at specific metrics
such as r-squared on our MSA for
regression and accuracy and
classification so you follow the
standard procedure splitting data and
training and test sets so for the emmy
music data set the data frame is this
big lots of columns and there was a
bunch of cleansing that was done
beforehand I can give you more details
if you ask me but let's assume that that
was sorted and data it now looks pretty
so the results for the regression this
computer is rather slow so I didn't want
to use it full of 500 trees because it
would take forever to run so this was
just more to compare like how would we
work with Python and R so I picked 60
trees I tried 100 and then I tried also
I started 10 and I use samples of 50,000
given I had 82,000 rows this is a
standard call for random forests this
are pretty much the parameters I gave
the function so if you do that and you
press ENTER in this computer the
training time will be 40 minutes for
this particular example but if you like
the st. country's was already over 10
minutes and depending on the sample size
and on M try as well and try I've read
it a few I took several values but to be
fair it wasn't a huge impact into the
rmse or the r-squared so I left it as a
default in this case and if you do this
and
and you apply your model you predict the
model in the test set you get your
r-squared of zero point five eight one
on the RMS CES fourteen point five two
eight seven which on its own they might
not mean a lot to you but let's compare
it now let's do the same extra line
Python so my parameters were sixty three
sixty trees the sample fifty thousand
this is pretty much your random for
aggressor um like the training time was
three minutes and seven seconds on this
computer and this was the RMS C and they
are squared so if you look at them
they're very similar but this was super
fast compared to the other one so I
guess Python one or zero and this is
sort of like the rough plotting so this
is pretty much what you get an R so you
have the predicted versus the real one
the actual one and this one for Python
so it looks very messy it's a big data
set but that's how it look likes ggplot2
one non ggplot2 zero so now we look at
feature importance so you can extract
watchword important features for each of
them so this is what you get an R so
these are some of the words some of the
questions that I told you about before
and they're classify according to the
increase in the MSE or basically present
percentage change and the node purity
using the Gini coefficient these are
some of the questions and this is how it
looks like so I know that the left are
super tiny but you can pretty much see
that here there's a sharp turn and over
there so this pretty much tell you what
about how important those features are
compared to the other ones and then if
you the same thing in Python and then
you list them the most up ten important
features according to this random forest
implementation and the second column
tells you how they compared to the r1 so
distinctive which was this particular
random forest op feature
was number seven in the r-1 catchy with
number three
like artist with number two etc etc so
they're not super super different then
um just so you can compare I also did
the general linear regression and then
you can also do multiple linear
regressions this ones I did in R and
this is pretty much the rmse that you
get so you see that's actually quite
similar ish this is not a random forest
they're not terrible so that's how good
as it gets and then if you the same
problem using classification this is
pretty much your confusion matrix this
is for our took eight minutes on
training time the out-of-bag error rate
and the icarus is zero point five six
seven and you can see that it's more or
less okay there's some miss
classification error over there you can
do exactly the same in python training
time is two point five six minutes to be
further predicts the prediction is
faster in our that the training time is
important one
so that's operations 0.56 f6 for the
classifier and python with slightly
better and well you can do the same
exercise of feature importance so here
the question somehow we're much more
consider important here are in our
python compared to our so again the
similar set of questions this is the
confusion matrix in are some cute
visualization and the same thing for
python so i haven't used the ggplot2 for
python so i hope it's better and well
once you do this type of exercise you
can reformulate the hypothesis and for
this i you can determine which features
account for most of the barians you can
do principal component analysis i did
this for the words dataset interestingly
enough you find that the features that
have a larger first principal component
distinctive untalented were some of the
cheers that both the random force in
Python and an are considered important
so that's nice to know
so you can try to make a simple model
choosing meaningful variables so I
choose this one's given the previous
visualization you can build a random
forest in R in Python in R the time of
your training decreases a lot becomes 15
minutes versus what I told you before
there was a long time and these are the
results you have the reduced model in
the full model so it's quite crappy on
the edges it's quite good in the center
so it seems you didn't lose much by the
chin most of the Bibles so well some
comments it is well-known that random
forests have shown to be biased towards
highly correlated variables so using
conditional inference trees you
ameliorate that bias so if you see the
party package in our do use conditional
inference trees so I could try to use
this implementation to see we get better
results for psychic learns
implementation you have the n jobs
parameter to paralyze training so that
is definitely better than the standard
random forest library and for a similar
feature nard you have to look at the big
RF package and then concluding remarks
so the key message of this talk was pick
the tool that is best for the job so we
saw the problem using both aren't Python
vs I could learn so there's clearly
constraints for addressing a given
problem and they might differ would
dictate the implementation of choice so
for people that are working into pushing
are generating data products may be
doing this type of things it's better to
important because it's easier to put
into the pipeline then if you're doing a
standalone analysis for which are might
be better is we're learning about both
implementations both arm Python vs I
could learn implementations have added
functions that allow the user to explore
the resulting model and its performance
so there's many different methods that
you can use on the predict object and
you can get further insights run the
force are great they give great accuracy
can handle many features does not
require cross validation and it even
estimates what variables are important
and finally keep an eye out for
interesting data having data that you're
interested in leads to more interesting
questions and reasons to explore new
methods add any trick to your bag so if
you're invested if you do astrophysics
and you're in love with astrophysics
then astrophysics ads are good for you
maybe not medical ones and the Emmy data
set is great
for test rights the set has a lot of
behavioral information on a subject that
everyone has some intuition on so
everyone pretty much knows about music
so you might have some intuition to feed
into those hypotheses and then to do
this Willet Python prediction using as
VMs and other majors firestation
techniques you could try to do full
factor analysis etc and explore the
different libraries that Python or are
might offer so thank you that's all so
could you say something about the
quality of the packages or well of
course this comes from limited
experience and this was very much an
approach as to how someone who is quite
familiar with one language might try to
the same thing you'll learn what it's
done in the other language I mean I'm
biased towards our because it's what I
know there's just so many libraries and
if you do statistical analysis this
again pretty much everything you ever
need is there but I was very impressed
with Python not only because it was fast
but also because it makes very easy to
just plug it into api's and this in this
particular example not but in others yes
now it becomes a bit tricky you're
trying to say to pull web data so in not
in this particular example but in others
you can definitely see how Python being
a general-purpose language may be may be
a tool of choice for specific problems I
mean I'm very far away from saying if
one is better or worse I don't think
you can say that it just depends on the
problem in scope that's what I wanted
that's type of message I want to get
across